اللي شهر بلفل والله
شهر على صحي بدور على بد طحين ما حاجه
الخبز بدنا بنور بدنا طحين بس
وخلص من يوم الثلاث اليوم موزعو طحين كل
العدد هذا اللي انت شايفه ارب ايام نايم ه
في الشارع كل ما تفصل اصالت بروحو معانه
مش طبيعيه كيلو طحين والله مع عننا في
الضور وهيك شايف اسال مين ما بدك هذا
الزلمه زيي وهذا زيي ل كلهم تحكوا هذا من
بالشارع كله على الفاضي من غير الطحين انت
اكلك وغذائك الطحين ع الفاضي ايش ما توفر
تجيب لي فول كيف بدي اكله تجيب لي تونه
كيف بدي
اكلها بجيب لك من الساعه اعه لهنيه الساعه
اعه عشان
الطحين بظل العصر لثلاث ايام لثلاث بقول
لك لاسبوعين ما عندي
طحين والله احنا في خنون من الشاطئ للشفا
ل اتحاد الكنائس ال لا في الاخر اجنا خن
يونس قاله الجنوب امن هي في طاقع في خن
يونس لا قام ولا قعد وفيش عنا طحين ومافيش
عنا مساعدات ولا اي حاجه احنا قاعدين في
مدرسه محمد الضره وفيش اننا ع ايام ما
شفنا اي حاجه قربت علينا لا امم المتحده
ولا اي شيء يعني الاسبوعين بدي كيس طحين
مش لاقي اللي بقول لك هذا كيس طحين 300
شيك هذا بقوللك 400 شيك بقول احنا مصاري
احنا طلعنا من الشاطئ معنا مصاري ق في حد
معه مصاري
بالمره قاعدين ب م خز الاولاد بيشحتوا في
الشارع من كل المدارس من اللي بروح بده
الرغيف اللي بده هذا ما فيش اي شي اي اي
شيء في الطحين الا تقف على الدور وعند ما
يجي الدور ما فيش طحين وبنقعد يومين
واسبوع واسبوعين احنا بنصبر يوم ويومين
وثلاثه بنشرب ماء وملح لكن في الوضع هذا
ننا بندور للصغار ليش لانه احن بنطلع على
الصغار اللي بياكل ورق شجر اللي بياكل امن
بالله في وضع بشوفه لا يبس عليه و السنه
ثلا ايام ولا حبه دوبنا دوبنا جنا كيلو اه
كيلو طحين من كل البلدنا كيلو كله غالي
وكله كوي ومش قادين ولا حاجه في البلد
البلد تعبانه
بالمره